[Applause]
Bob Woodward and ktk a question for you
- how important is it for the press to
band together when reporters like Jim
Acosta are attacked by the
administration it is I you know we've
got reporters this week who have worked
in China and Uzbekistan who were giving
advice to reporters working in America I
mean that tells you something about the
world we're in right where they are
haven't so k this is how you handle this
sort of situation where press freedom is
getting eroded and the one thing a piece
of advice from the reporter in China was
the aim of the government will be to try
to divide you because if they can divide
the press corps then they can play one
off against each other and they weaken
them but I think that we're taking the
bait in the press and Trump is just
throwing it out on that table and saying
you know you're the enemy of the people
and then we get all steamy and
emotionally unhinged about oil now the
way to work together is when the New
York Times or the BBC have a great story
for the Washington Post to follow it and
dig and get specifics and make the case
for the truth and that means lots of
work and let's face it we've become lazy
and we have to stop becoming lazy
[Applause]
following the times for the New York
Times in the BBC to give stories - but I
thought that's where we were heading but
it's about the quality of information I
mean New York Times had a great story on
Trump's taxes and how the real estate
market in New York City works and we
wrote one story about it we should do
more we should have got his tax returns
I should have got his tax return I feel
see every day about not getting his text
it's so important not to be baited by
every tweet because Trump is playing the
press and and that that is his skill you
talked about his Sarah talked about him
as the ideal eight-year-old I see him as
like a cunning twelve-year-old I mean
maybe that's a subject for debate but
he's the classic 8th grade 8th grade
bully and he knows exactly where to poke
someone where it hurts McCain said
something so smart before he died he
said you can't be the car alarm that's
constantly going off pick your battles
pick them wisely ok this is for the one
Sarah I think it's about pushing and
pushing and pushing and pushing the way
he does so he repeats and repeats and
repeats and there is something about
writing multiple stories and pushing and
pushing and pushing and being that car
alarm I'm guessing another because
that's when people stop even noticing
and the risk is that audiences tune off
everybody thinks oh this is normal
because we heard this 15 times yesterday
and every tweet gets reported and the
trouble is while you're distracted
report it's really hard to cover Trump
because every day there are 15 my jaw is
on the floor things that you could be
covering and you don't have time to go
down to the border and look what's
happening with families and see how many
people are being deported and go around
the country and find out what's
happening you under this administration
the bill talked about the dictator
playbook and the great you know line
attributed to Stalin is the death of one
person is a tragedy in the death of a
million is the statistic one lie will
haunt Bill Clinton into his grave but a
million Trump lies you can't remember a
single one of them but get me if I may
be we let important stories go by like
the tax cut the tax cut is one of the
great deceits of all time it's designed
that you know there were six people who
made the tax cut for people from
Congress to people the Treasury
secretary from Goldman Sachs
and Gary Cohen who was the president of
Goldman Sachs they sat around a table
and I think they had to go in and wipe
the drool off the table because these
people were so happy to have all this
money that they can give to rich people
and they took the corporate tax rate
from thirty five percent to twenty one
percent Trump was disappointed he wanted
to take it to fifteen percent and
everyone got a tax break but the working
people's tax break expires but the
corporate tax break does not and why are
we letting this kind of oh well that
happen and essentially Trump ran on
saying oh isn't it great this wonderful
tax cut it has given us a wonderful
economy well if you you know talk to
economists left center and right
we now have an additional one trillion
dollar deficit because of this
somebody's gonna have to pay for that
and that's what the Republican classic
candidate would say remember these kind
of Republicans when we were just about
the dead and we can't be running up the
debt that's what a Republican classic I
would say Russia right the enemy and not
absolutely there's more of them left and
what exactly can I say one quick thing
on on the media and sort of the
propaganda and how it's working and it
ties back into your conversation about
Millennials so I sit and focus with a
lot of Millennials and and it's working
they are tuning out of mainstream news
because they don't want to hear anymore
and and and you know I was sitting with
some Millennials about two months ago
and they didn't know who Mueller was
they don't know anything about the
investigation right so it's a disconnect
and then and then of course to your
point then they don't vote right so so
what Trump is doing is diabolic but it
is actually work yeah that's the problem
the people within the ears of a dog
whistle or they say things that they
don't even there they say we like Russia
just to be
I mean it's just mr. make the Lib tardes
cry that's a lot of what it is and to
the tax thing is just like it it doesn't
take much on Google to fake to follow
the money and see how things altered us
out I mean billionaires cost Americans
money more than anybody else we're
subsidizing that garbage they pay their
workers Amazon valuated at a trillion
dollars in 2017 paid zero dollars in
taxes that's what the text I mean it's
bananas crazy no no this is where I
guess the questions are for two people
today this is for you and me has it
become increasingly difficult to make
others laugh since Trump took office I
guess they're saying because you know
the premises are the punch lines I guess
that's what the question means for sure
and also I don't think it's different
more difficult I mean there's more
material than ever right I mean it's
it's insane I mean usually presidents
have one thing you know Clinton was
horny and Bush was stupid this guy's
everything horny and stupid and he's
you're right exactly I mean they're like
they're like jokes out of the Soviet
Union right it was funny you went when
you weren't in the gulag right exactly
all right Thank You audience Thank You
panel
well apology